ربما كان راكب سفينة سياحية
يطفو في خليج المكسيك لمدة تصل إلى
15 ساعة بعد صعوده على
متن سفينة سياحية كرنفالية في وقت متأخر من
ليلة الأربعاء ، فهو على قيد الحياة اليوم
بسبب مهمة الإنقاذ المذهلة التي
وضعها نيك فالنسيا من خفر السواحل الأمريكي.
أحدث
معجزة عيد الشكر هذه
، أعتقد أنها نوعًا ما تضرب الحياة الطبيعية
خارج الماء هنا ، وهي
عملية إنقاذ معجزة بمناسبة عيد الشكر في البحر
بعد أن ذهب أحد ركاب سفينة سياحية كرنفال
إلى فوق سطح السفينة وهو
يلوح في طائرة هليكوبتر تابعة لخفر السواحل
تحوم فوقه بينما كان يقاتل من أجل
البقاء.  قالت شركة Cruise Company إن
الرجل البالغ من العمر 28 عامًا قد تم الإبلاغ عنه
يوم الخميس في حوالي الساعة 12 ظهرًا ، وكان قد
شوهد آخر مرة في حوالي الساعة 11 مساءً يوم الأربعاء من قبل
أخته وهو يترك بارًا على متن السفينة
التي غادرت نيو أورليانز باوند متوجهة إلى
كوزوميل المكسيك في أي وقت من الساعة 11.  مساء
يوم الأربعاء يوم أه كان من الممكن أن
يدخل Waterway لذلك كان من الناحية الواقعية
يمكن أن يكون في الماء لمدة 15
ساعة إضافية قبل أن نكون  قادرًا على
إنقاذه بنجاح نظرًا لأن الكثير من
الوقت قد مر منذ آخر مرة شوهدت
فيه ، كانت عملية الإنقاذ صعبة بشكل خاص
لفهمك تعلم
أننا واجهنا تأخيرًا كبيرًا كلما طال
وجود شخص ما في الماء كلما
زادت منطقة البحث
كان الوقت بالتأكيد جوهريًا في
النهاية ، كان الطاقم على متن سفينة شحن
يقع على بعد حوالي 20 ميلاً جنوب
جنوب غرب ممر لويزيانا حيث كان
خفر السواحل قادرًا على ركوب طائرة هليكوبتر
ورافعة الرجل من الماء إلى
أمان وهو في المستشفى يخضع
للتقييم الطبي و  وبحسب ما ورد في
حالة مستقرة ، فقد كان قادرًا على التعرف
على اسمه ، وأكد أنه كان
الشخص الذي سقط في البحر ، وكان
يظهر عليه علامات انخفاض حرارة الجسم ،
والجفاف
والصدمة.  خفر السواحل والملاح الذي
رصد الضيف في الماء
وإرادة العيش هو شيء رائع  عليك أن
تحسب في كل حالة بحث وإنقاذ
رغبة هذا الرجل في البقاء على قيد الحياة تاركًا
حتى أولئك الذين أنقذوه في رهبة ،
هذا كما قلت لواحدة من
أطول المعجزات التي سمعت عنها
وواحدة فقط من معجزات عيد الشكر
تلك الولايات المتحدة  يخبر خفر السواحل شبكة CNN أن
المياه التي عثر عليها الرجل كانت
تقدر بحوالي 70 درجة فهرنهايت وكان من
الممكن أن تساعد في إبقائه على
قيد الحياة للساعات التي كان يطفو فيها
في خليج المكسيك ، وفي الوقت نفسه
يبحث المحققون في
كيفية ذهابه إلى البحر وما الذي حدث بالضبط.  فعل من أجل
البقاء